I think symbol this is the only time
greatest comes like that we've ever had
probably considered at the moment the
best of all time my goodness what a
spectacular plan of fight fire with fire
you know the gun catch them up when they
least expect it how does he do that
sleepy taking down rain first next in
line is solo fighter that's what I can
say it oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
wasn't gonna miss a single bullet but
that is the full reset now while there
are plenty of pros were naturally gifted
and practice a ton simple just stands
out he's different
he makes the craziest plays and somehow
they work ok I'm sure he would probably
say that you know watch out for
connector he has balls of steel
incredible aim unbelievable game sense
and somehow he still grinds to get
better I just quit everything that ICS
so when we had online I always played I
never went out
maybe if I invite some friends I spent
time with them play playstation and be
turned back and after just to feel at
the night yeah just I try to play as
much as possible just upgrade my game
and but simple is cursed
despite his godlike skills he just never
manages to win when it counts
see despite literally everyone in the
world saying that simple is the best
player to ever touch csgo he doesn't
have the trophies to back up those
claims sure there's a lot of players
that couldn't win major before you know
it's maybe too early how always think
that if I didn't win some then I need to
work on myself and to find more my
mistakes maybe it's not inside him maybe
it's outside or maybe it's my
communication or maybe when I'm teased
it sometimes you know so I'm always
trying to fix myself some including
simple himself have chopped up his
misfortunes to his explosive temper but
those same high octane emotions people
would drive simple simple spent years
dealing with a band he got back in his
1.6 days and often his team
considered him toxic but in 2016 after
being part of several lower tier
officers simple decided to live out his
dream with Team Liquid the Ukrainian
superstar even moved to the US to play
with the NA roster leaving his friends
his family everything he'd ever known
behind the men think that they won't be
liquid it's to be champion to be one of
the best player is them in the month
simple spent overseas he had two shots
at major victory first came MLG Columbus
Columbus was supposed to be the major
that made simple sacrifice worth it the
major that justified leaving behind
everything he knew and loved but it
wasn't meant to be
here he comes once again the first base
is a trend he's gonna hit the ground
there's cold off
how does he do this corner safely
velocity with your play unthinkable
seats there on the B apartments they
need a huge play
but that's something I'm never gonna see
ever again and there it is cold it's
going to take his head off and
luminosity will find themselves in the
grand finals against Navi next in ESL
one cologne the bomb is making its way
back down - looks like it's gonna be an
a hit a nice shot from simple colds
gonna be taking down a leash and that
was in puf dog now simple has a lot of
work to do he's got the a cane hand and
he's up on the train they're gonna be
pushing in now only 30 seconds left and
he needs backup quick simple picking up
one more deal sprays and that's a third
one coming through now all on coldzera
one versus three it seems like Sybil has
done it again that's a quad kill to shut
down sk this time simple came even
closer to lifting the trophy only to see
a major title slip through his fingers
once again all in the details easy for
sk to pick it up here trying to walk
through the smoke but it's just not
gonna happen sk gaming second major
championship in a row they
widows those majors were simples to win
he had come so close to his coronation
to truly being the best player in the
world to having the trophies that went
with his skills but he lost I feel like
it's first chance to be his team and
quality for $1,000,000 major and then we
start losing because maybe of me because
I didn't hit my shots I feel so sad
after two devastating major losses
simples temper was getting the better of
him allegedly his relationship with his
teammates was strained and it was
hurting the team dynamic I knew him and
adrenaline get along very well I knew it
would probably be like a ticking time
bomb and you know only a matter of time
until it exploded where simple made it
either him or a dren and you know
obviously as we can see now it's that
was what it was I miss my girlfriend to
friends friends I miss everything from
Ukraine but despite those struggles
simple always put on a show sit double
smokes in the same place it was jumping
this is this is a paid job a simple
incidence us in this kind is absolutely
unbelievable he's the x-factor Patil II
could there is no question after simple
departure liquids 2017 was a bit of a
write-off but he rebounded and became
one of the best teams in the world by
2019 leading some to wonder what could
have been if simple it's stuff around
simple did what he thought was right at
the time he did what he thought would
bring him closer to winning that major
that he felt he deserved
he joined not has been sare Navi were
Ukrainian an organization invited me so
proud that I'm gonna join his team it's
been about three and a half years since
simple join Navi and in that time the
team has made it to the semi-final and
grand final of a major and they couldn't
win either
there's who's gonna look the right way
at the right time are they going to peak
holding it now and there is it it's just
a flavor
so far simple has achieved the exact
same things he did on a liquid except
this time it took him far longer and it
had nothing to do with his individual
performance his ease on that 14 seconds
they've gotta get out simple get so we
want to return jumps up and somehow
point Sergey but he hasn't found the
palm he will now and he goes away from
default I can see wait I don't want to
get an A to the Elsa knows there's a
plank and he also knows he needs
actually get the first one he's got a
chance he knows al who's up for a long
chunk of his time on the team simple was
carrying Navi players and just couldn't
hold their own
oh my god what is that transfer on the
third and simple it sure Caswell no way
he hit that third shot that makes up for
it well too little too late as they will
get the defuse through both Zeus and
Edward were older players on the verge
of retirement Guardian was no longer
playing at his peak seized seemed
perpetually stuck in training mode and
simple had to try his best to make it
work on his own I just want to win every
sin with them we're gonna practice more
harder than before everyone understand
that it's really important I mean it's
really important to practice when
practice win even if you're losing you
should stay as a team and we were just
trying and moving forward you know every
time we fixing mistakes talking with
each other
fixing personal issues you know they're
just good trying yeah the world of csgo
had changed significantly since simples
early major runs in 2016 and going into
2019 he needed a major win more than
ever it used to be that all simple
needed was a major to cement his legacy
as the greatest csgo player of all time
but at that point when teams like a
straw list were swimming in majors
simple needed at least one to just stay
in the conversation csgo just isn't the
same game anymore in 2016 simple could
hard carry but
it's all about teamwork individual skill
just can't carry a player as far these
days even a player is gifted as simple
cadet about mass travel ships psychology
of command yet the pedroka more
internationally much pokemon pretty much
too because there's pretty much to a mr.
altitude it's a mechanical dvds
latitudes Roboto cat regulate the Nemo's
prosthetic actors really dvds to agree
keeper agrees hero but a significant
roster shake-up finally led simple to
believe that he was on a team worthy of
his talent a team that he could believe
in I think it's more individual skill
now more understanding of game it's much
better like Chema strain team and we
work with our college it's really hard
and I think like all players on other
level right now like every year the
teams become more stronger they become
more professional and
their dedication become much better
electronic and stand for doing what
electronic and simple duper simple
arriving at a very very big way through
simple flaking and he lands a
two-for-one even hits the third as well
I don't go down eventually but Navi
slaughtering players on this be bomb
site symbol wasn't that much closer to
getting everything he wanted he was
finally on the right team and he had all
the momentum in the world but in 2019
simple faced a new obstacle a challenger
for the title he'd held for so long the
best individual player in the world
rings out first he's had enough he's
gonna keep going through it he doesn't
really care this boy Eric
the closure
could make it up sigh whoo a young
French up-and-comer was ranked number
one in the world by hltv in 2019
snatching the title right from under
simples nose now simple didn't have the
title or the trophies he needed the
major more than ever
whether he was out to avenge his loss
title or hobby finally clicked simple
bounced back just perfect oh and simple
he needs a multi kill first found twist
aggressing they have to double peak his
name number one in the game he's done it
again voice no but if he was to go for
the ambitious jump to check it he can
jump on those boxes but instead he's
gonna go gets the fright but this is so
nice from liquid he's holding it and
enough to do it I don't believe it
simple one versus one now Dupree he will
make his way towards the bomb site 90%
clutch rate on this map we saw him win
one against liquid versus four he's only
got it again the percentage goes up
again Henry 12:1 for Navi it's going to
be simple and flamey-o just seem to be
taking matters into their own hands
ladies and gentlemen there it is your
champions are gonna be Navi at that 3-0
clean sweep here in the grand final this
is a legit team I didn't have much
expectations for the whole squad Navi
over the years have never really had a
comprehensive liner that makes sense for
all the roles of Bilbo finally
behind the firepower simple electronic
they'd caught the pieces they need to be
a world-class team symbol was playing so
well that nobody could deny he was the
best once again with this roster you
have brighter future okay I mean we
don't know what's gonna happen but still
finally after all that strife and
anguish
it looks like 2020 simple year the year
he was finally going to win his major
but simple is cursed
due to Cova 19 the real major was
cancelled a global pandemic swiped
simples best shot and major victory to
date away from him he would have been at
his peak in time for Rio but now that
tournament the years only major has been
pushed back by months will na'vi still
be the best team in the world by
november we'll simple still be the best
player could he finally win a major only
time will tell but csgo is a game that
changes fast for all we know Australia's
could be back on top by then he hasn't
won a major and that gives him no doubt
probably some sleepless nights along the
way and you know it's something that's
personal to him that he wants to do he's
come close of course on a couple of
occasions and eventually I think at some
point in his career as one of the
greatest players that has played
counter-strike
in history and undoubtedly one of the
top three players over the last five
years consecutively and arguably still
the best player in the world in my eyes
and is a concern for him and his fans
that he hasn't won a major yet of course
the true tragedy of simple is that the
nagging question of who the true coat of
csgo is could have been answered years
ago if simple had only won a major even
one he would have silenced the doubters
forever but simple still has time but I
don't think we can start talking about
time's running out to this man this is a
man who is 22 years of age 22 and
although he's been around for what seems
like forever he's still only 22 that
means by the likes of forest and neo and
get right he's probably got another
eight years to win a major that's 16
Agis if we carry on on the same I'm
pretty sure in fact I would stake my
house on it he's gonna pick up a major
at some point in the future no matter
what happens in the future though one
thing is for certain
despite simples terrible luck he knows
exactly what he wants and he's giving
his all to get it I want to win every
tournament in the world I want to have
to be a new era of not to spin so I'm
just waiting because you're walking it's
gonna be picked up on camera unlike no
worries I'm not sure if it was or wasn't
Andrew will tell me later if it was
picked up on the mic but we'll find out
I don't know the mic picked up my
girlfriend just said that it's not fun
because I'm not messing up as much as
normal it's only fun when I [ __ ] up my
lines that's the only time she has fun
with me filming here outside of [ __ ] up
more lines for you how about that
[Music]